are you ready to gamble dude chi-ching
what I'm singing like damn I'm in the
negative already that's alright I'm
taking the total woodsy approach this
week you had hundreds on everything yes
I did just ruin the whole show damn
that's amazing believe it go what is up
what is good good friday morning or
whatever weekend day it is that you're
listening this is our big show to look
ahead at the games Thursday night we're
gonna do a little pre cap again Sunday
Monday we're gonna make all of our bets
we have our bank we have our new $1600
of bleacher bucks we're gonna kind of go
over thing now but first thanks again to
everyone that watched the show and
thanks again to everyone that shared
that clip of Sean McVeigh remembering
place cuz that thing was and free with
Mazel Tov everybody Mazel Tov Amos was a
little upset though because you nailed a
number of the place to it just got
edited out I know thanks leader report
thanks for supporting your own what do
you think of all the retweets I mean I I
don't know yes no all I know is I
watched the show and I scrolled down the
comments which I was a little scared to
do yeah it's always negative and I was
very pleased to see a lot of positivity
yeah and that made me feel good because
the internet is full of negativity and
to see something like that must mean
people somewhat liked it it's a good
common sense man the sims Aleph go
faithful the homies have been incredible
and it really is cool like I love what I
look in the comments section it's not
just this was awesome but it's like they
seemed more natural than last week I
like to get them segmented there was a
guy who commented I love the show but
dislike the pan of the camera because it
made us dizzy I was like that's a good
production note thanks for sharing yeah
like we're at a point now where and I
love the DMS to that we get on the sims
and left go account on my account it's
like don't forget us when you go big
time like I don't think that the sims
Aleph go homies realize that you're the
only people that we care about that's
right
like if you want to be honest like when
people at work are like
I think that you guys should do this we
go men are really interested but when
the homies are like we like this we go
okay we're gonna do that that's the only
reason we're where we are right to be
honest right before we keep going yeah
you have some information about yourself
oh wait do you guys want to just get it
out of the way okay first thing is no
before we even get there okay I think we
need to thank Sean McVeigh that's the
first thing okay you show me John McVay
for taking time out he's the man did the
young wizard of the NFL and for the Rams
to be as cool as they were for us to be
out there and make their head coach a
part of a segment like that where he was
probably like what the hell is this yeah
we didn't prepare him at all at all so
he is just it just speaks to him and
what kind of guy he is all the people
that think we were fake and like giving
him the plays ahead of time what no I
didn't even know what camera look at
like he had no we had five minutes we're
going through the raw footage today but
we were we were out there obviously Sean
walked off the practice field after
practice came over the cameras might
have had an idea what was about to
happen but honestly I'm not sure he did
and even if he did know he had just
gotten done coaching practice yes and he
just did that cold yes just off the top
of his afterwards he goes I go he goes
he goes he goes left go great to meet
you I love your work on the show and I
was like hold on I'm gonna Ford this
yeah no all right let's do it later then
it's the 23andme that we talked about
the other day we'll be stopped coming up
on the Tuesday podcast we are gonna
reveal the bloodlines of Chris Sims
where he came from and we know there's a
10% surprise don't give it away boy you
want to know the best part of actually
than one of the funniest things I
thought I'll give this part away is I
was like 51 percent Neanderthal that's
an option it is an option to see if like
you're from the like the German
Neanderthal tribe and I was like you
neanderthal no no never again I'm very
proud of my Neanderthals I know you're a
Neanderthal because you go I'm not gonna
give away anything I'm just gonna tell
you what the largest percent of my body
make are you saying dumb I love it all
right so no yes so now that Fenric has a
little bit more time you can hang out
with
ventric is gonna be our bank he's gonna
be the casino he's gonna be the guy that
when we make our bets we enter them with
Fender ik so Josh do you want to let
everyone know where we currently stand
yeah I got a pulled up on my computer so
coming off the last week week one just
reminder everybody they get 1600
Bleacher bucks every week to bet last
week Chris Simms you finished at
negative 80 going nine and seven in your
bets
losing Seattle plus two and a half for
$500 was killed me that was a bad one
for I mean I smell smell me later ruined
it I mean he ruined it
left go on the other hand no I mean Von
Miller oh yeah I mean he ruined it he
ruined the game for me it's good to see
that he's back he is back he kind of had
a down year last year but he is back
left go you finished up $900 you went 12
and 4 against the spread last week only
games you lost Giants Texans Chargers
and Cowboys you got wrong your biggest
bet last week $200 on the Baltimore
Ravens minus 7 cover that one no problem
and that's where we pick up this week so
you had a 1 $200 bet last week and it's
really funniest I think we completely
changed philosophies you did good all
right I didn't like the bets this week
I'm not lying
and I felt really comfortable no it does
not mean anyone that does not history
has told us that you're better at this
than me so that's true yeah alright
let's get a go on Thursday night's game
is already broken down Thursday night so
here's what we're doing if you want to
listen to the preview of Ravens Bengals
check out the Thursday morning podcast
our film we did a deep dive into both
sides of the ball we're going to app
recap again but we're gonna keep it to
like one and a half minutes okay last
week we did 20 minutes on a Thursday
night game that already concluded in
retrospect not the best idea yeah so
Sims what happened last night
in Ravens Bengals well what happened is
the Ravens were just there sick of being
bullied by the Cincinnati Bengals it's a
new year for the Ravens they're a
different football team altogether
I mean it's creativity in the offense
for the first time I'm most beautiful to
watch and we saw that in week 1 against
the bills I wasn't sure if it would
carry over against the Cincinnati
Bengals but no it shows that Marty
mourning wag has truly starting to put
his stamp on this offense a little bit
and this this Ravens the team is a
different team this year
they're healthy they are the all
kick-ass team if you asked me to take a
team in a bar fight right now I'm taking
the Ravens they got more meat for your
buck than anybody so how much did you
bet on the Ravens well I bet a hundred
dollars on the Ravens nice yes I did
that's a pick'em game I do think it's
closed the Bengals very encouraging week
one when I saw often sleeve but they
fell into the trap again last night of
what are they offensively yeah I don't
know they had some week one surprises
but they did nothing creative to beat
this Baltimore Ravens team and the
Ravens 12320 nice yeah so I went back
and looked and you know my stat about
home teams on Thursday night right now
last year against the spread home teams
were ten and four but I also looked the
last three years of Thursday Night
Football being up there week to the
first Thursday Night Football game the
road team has won every single one he
hasn't really snuck in there I could
tell last night that the Ravens were
well rested from their game against the
Buffalo Bills right and I can also see
they were motivated from being kicked
out of the playoffs by the Bengals now
beat 17 last personal it was personal
you could see it on their faces last
heartily I mean Suggs was the other
thing I realized too using the Bengals
look good let's not forget they were
inside against the Colts right Ravens
were a different team and I ended up
betting how much you bet $50 on the
Ravens it's still Thursday Night
Football it's still a close game I
didn't feel confident to go 100 I put
$50 in the Ravens and the pick the week
to thing is very interesting the point
you're bringing up because the why you
know why because it's they've already
prepared for it they've already taken
the offseason they go it's gonna be a
short week let's spend part of the
season on the bengals get ready for week
exactly right alright so we're both
going Ravens yeah and if you watched our
show alley the newspaper guy he took the
Bengals so if Ali goes to an Owen you go
Owen - I don't know you were stupid
little Sims last you know in the Falcons
yeah alright moving on I wasn't stupid
little Sims of a stupid little Sarkisian
and overrated and ratty Ryan next game
moving on to Sunday the Carolina
Panthers
heading to Atlanta to take on the
Falcons line for this game that we're
going with is the Falcons minus six
which was incredible to see Caroline is
coming off a game which their defense
was all over the Cowboys now again how
much of that is the cowboy system they
are again without their middle
linebacker that took your spleen Thomas
Davis but Shaq Thompson looks good who
Luke Kuechly looks good they're facing
an Atlanta team that just lost the
middle core and speed and hits of their
defense Deon Jones is gone Keon O'Neill
is gone both on IR Matt Ryan there at
home he's better at home Sims
let me hear your breakdown and your pick
well my break do I want to put my bed up
first no let's break down okay so this
the big thing is I was impressed with
Carolina Carolina last week just their
team in general this is a different team
the offense has more to defend certainly
with McCaffrey the cam noon design runs
from a North Turner very impressive I do
worry about no bolson I do worry about
lack of maybe a difference maker on the
outside to maybe stretch the defense at
times Torrey Smith could be that guy
not totally a hundred percent sold on
that also would like to see DJ more
involved wasn't involved much in week
one at all no but here's the other thing
uh this Carolina defense can play
man-to-man for the first time in a long
time and I think that's what's
encouraging to me it's still a very good
front and I know Atlanta's got talent on
the offense and a pretty good offensive
line and they can run the ball don't
know what Devonta Freeman is gonna be I
think that scares me everything about
the Falcon scares me right now I mean
this is a Seattle defense and they don't
have kam chancellor and Bobby Wagner in
their prime right that's what I'm trying
to say here with Nokia O'Neal and Deon
Jones so I look at that that scares me I
would a Atlanta game planning is really
what scares me more than anything and
can Steve Sarkisian have enough creative
things in his pocket to create plays for
that offense and so at the end of the
day Josh I would like to place $100 bet
on the Carolina Panthers to cover that
six point spread said okay thank you
that's why I wanted
so we were all waiting for yeah I mean
they eat little birdie here's here's the
one thing I want you to do yeah I want
you to tell me since you bet a hundred
on everything right which are the games
that you would have gone [ __ ] okay so
this is one of them yeah I wanted I
really am annoyed that I went this way
to this week I really am
I wanted to go I like the victory
demonstrated do one pick and go I want
to go ham this is one of the games I
looked at but it's week two and I'm
scared still you're still at the betting
window if you want to put $200 on this
game we can make it up somewhere else I
don't I probably won't be able to figure
out that but yes
this is a game I thought about going
hard on yes but I also play into this
factor always especially early early in
the year divisional game divisional game
Falcons have a little extra time and
right they're desperate I mean you go oh
until you're you're fighting up our big
uphill enough talking out of the loser
in this game Falcons have won in and
covered for the last five meetings
between the two teams Cam Newton is an
11 and 4 as an underdog since 2015 just
interesting yeah there are some injuries
got a lot of injuries on the Panthers
offensive line every to you and if Trey
Turner misses with a concussion oh
that's super super bad right but Devonta
Freeman missed as well in addition to
Deon Jones and Keyon O'Neill fantasy
thing from Lefko with Olsen out Devin
Funchess is the play Devin Funchess gets
a lot more with us now but I looked at
it I put a hundred and fifty on the
Panthers because I can't believe it's it
they're getting six points it didn't
seem I can I totally understand the
extra rest but I think Carolina is a
good team and I look at Atlanta and I go
I don't know what they're gonna be like
without those two guys yeah Christian
McCaffrey is going to have a monster
game Atlanta lets you catch the ball to
the running backs underneath and then
goes hey Deon jones cannon he'll catch
that guys they're not there and we
talked about cam who he's been more he
would certainly seem to work and will
run and throw the short pass yes so I
look at that game and this was one where
I had even more on but because it's
divisional game and because I don't know
if I can trust the Carolina Panthers
that much I don't have I can't trust
Norv Turner
but when I saw +6 I thought it was gonna
be Falcons - - yeah not sick I didn't
either
I know I've just chickened out you're
right the extra time I didn't think
about that's okay all your other points
were good the Carolina 150 yeah so you
own 115 you win 50 on the first game yes
all right I like this next game we're
going with here Indianapolis Colts at
the Washington Redskins the Colts coming
off a 34 to 23 loss in week one to the
Bengals and for the Redskins coming off
of a win against the Arizona Cardinals
Redskins spread here - 6 - 6 at home
take it away ok I think for the Colts
first of all there's some encouraging
things from what we saw last week on the
offensive side of the ball now I don't
think they're gonna be able to run the
ball a whole lot and I don't see that
really changing maybe it does in a few
weeks but I don't know if it's gonna
change this week I still do think Andrew
Luck and his ability to sit in the
pocket and make big time throws down the
field is something to be reckoned with
and this Washington defense I do like a
whole lot I don't think this old line is
going to be overpowered by this
Washington defensive line as far as
giving him time to throw the football
right the Washington D line I got a lot
of respect for it I certainly do hey the
secondary in Washington got some good
pieces but I'm not blown away by it
right so I do think that Andrew Luck
will be able to have his way the
Redskins on the other hand I think
they're gonna have their way with the
Indianapolis Colts offense as well the
big thing will be when it's time to
strike and make big plays will charlie
check down make those plays so from that
okay I clearly think Washington will win
this football game but I don't think
they're gonna win by a lot and Josh Josh
aka Johnny the Hammond over here I'm
gonna place $100 bet on the Indianapolis
Colts and Andrew really I am I think
they stay within six in this football
game yes
the Andrew Luck Factor man that's great
so Andrew Luck when does he look good
simps when he's indoors not that high
what is tiwa Hilton good when he's
indoors and at home not only the
outdoors yeah they're gonna be playing
was he gonna be really rainy it's the
hurricane floor
it's coming right into South Carolina
that game is gonna be a mess right well
that's like four states up the three
states out but it's okay all the reports
are it should be a little bit sloppy am
my thing is this no why Indian I look at
the weather you know I did you know why
Indianapolis in my opinion he's a shark
cover didn't look good or was able to be
in that game because of sloppy turnovers
from Cincinnati I hear you I know that
you're looking at Alex Smith and you're
going when's he gonna take the shot I'm
looking at Alex Smith and going when's
he gonna have the turnover he's not
Indies not gonna get him this week I
would also say that Washington knows who
their offenses you just talked about on
Thursday night that Cincinnati didn't
Cincinnati didn't know their offense and
still put up 20-something points with
her off yes but they had a good game
playing last week that's where I just
wanna I'm gonna know that I'm washing
this way than what I saw Washington I
really liked what they're gonna do
offensively yeah
luck of his 53 throws four of them were
more than 20 yards down the field right
and if there's one defensive coach that
I think that I like to really figure out
what a team does and take advantage is
Greg Manaus key sure guess what else
Greg mineski is the former DC of the
Colts right Greg minovsky revenge games
I got Andrew Luck comparing hits in the
Bengals games to a car crash it's at
home I predicted before the year that
Washington starts off to a no I think
they finished to a No and Josh I'd like
to enter a bet of $100 for Washington -
six okay moving on next he was gonna
make that possibly a lock but now you're
kind of scaring me
after I talked what do you think I look
at the weather report the weather the
report is concerning um I just think it
needs a different team on the road -
there is I don't put a whole lot of
stock into it early in the year because
it's not like it's but but it's not like
I was thinking it's not gonna be cold
it's not gonna be that way yeah but I
threw a nano it's not about I don't
think about the coldest if I look at
Indy and I just think they're a team
that's built for their Stadium yeah and
now they're going to the grass I don't
know so I just have a question I just
gotta say I don't have the faith that
they're gonna blow out the Colts that's
six points blowing out well yeah it
I could see them maybe winning by they
can be up by 10 and then Andrew Luck's
got the ball in the fourth quarter and
he drives him down and now it's a
three-point game and then Andrew Luck
gets the ball back one more time with 48
seconds left and Kenney make magic
that's the [ __ ] that scares me in these
matchups because alex smith night now
put you away when he was supposed to he
might not I mean Arizona had a chance to
get back in that game but I mean those
are the little things it's week two and
I'm just not willing to go out and a
limb on something like this one okay guy
your points are on I'm not doing that
okay next game here Houston add
Tennessee left goes AFC champion Texans
coming off of a 27-20 loss to the
Patriots in week one
the Titans coming off a 27-20 loss to
the Dolphins in week one spread for this
game Houston minus 1.5 on the road
Houston - one and a half on the road to
avoid service okay let's start with the
Tennessee Titans right Tennessee Titans
the defensive side of the ball it's it's
it's admirable I mean they got good
secondary play I like the way they look
back there their D lines pretty big and
stout I still think for whatever reason
too many people are open on the field of
times now they play a mixture of
everything and Miami move the ball on
the Tennessee Titans it made some big
plays - I'm Kenny Stills the yes now the
the other side of that is I you know
against that defense deshaun Watson in
Houston hey I'm a little concerned with
their own line and the state of what it
is right now I am to a degree there's no
doubt I mean Shawn Chow Henderson going
down it's a big deal I don't know if the
Tennessee Titans front again is a
dominant enough to actually take over
the game from that manner and I think
DeSean Watson on that offense you're
gonna see a whole different team from
them this week now flip it over
I like this Houston Texans defense a
whole lot they gave Tom Brady and
company a very tough time reading your
note yeah in the second half when watt
and them started click they had their
way right exactly that was great to see
because I don't feel like that's being
conveyed in the public right no I that
would be a game like if Houston and the
Pats play again in week 16 or let's just
say whatever I would go oh that's gonna
be a pickup game either way this is my
big concern Marcus Mariota it's an
shoo he can't throw right now I don't
know what else to say
the two interceptions weren't that good
and again it's not just the
interceptions its completions that I
don't even like do you remember them on
the goal line of the goal line stand on
offense he throws a ball the guy's wide
open to the flat takes forever to get it
to him ball gets knocked down on third
and one on the goal line fourth and goal
throws have got a wide open guy in the
flat throws it to him complete pass but
it's behind him and the guy has to
juggle his body and figure out how to
get going straight and he gets tackled
before he gets there I don't like the
way Mariota looks I don't trust him this
sounds like a game that you would have
been I would have it's just it's week
two and I DeSean scares me a little but
Josh I would like to place a bet with
deshaun Watson $100 on the Houston
Texans no suspension no suspension so
let me give you some betting information
yeah in the last 14 games against the
Titans against the spread the Texans are
11 and 3 hmm in their last six games at
home in September the Titans straight up
winning or losing or 1 and 5 they lose
games in September at home it's just not
the right place to play this started off
as a big bet for me and I brought it
down just because it's an AFC South
battle and divisional games kind of
scare me sometimes even though I'm gonna
be hypocritical and later you're gonna
see I'm gonna put more money on
divisional games I look at Houston and I
go they are the only team that one side
of the ball I know what I'm gonna get I
know what I'm gonna get out of the
Texans defense and if I know that the
Titans are gonna have a hard time
running the ball which is when every
time they won last year it was a big
Derrick Henry performance and I know
that the Texans D is firing all
cylinders I read all your notes about
Watt and Clow knees not gonna have those
tackles to face again right well now it
means gonna have Taylor lawanna yeah
good thing cuz he definitely had a
concussion protocol that's the thing
yeah I don't know
he got knocked he got knocked silly but
it's gonna require Mariota to play
really well at home and I don't trust
that right and the other side I know
maybe we get will fuller back and I look
at the Texans offense and I go man I
don't really like their their old line
but do the Titans have anyone to really
take advantage I said I don't my point -
it's a good deal I'm good but it's not
like the Houston Texas d-line that can
take over a game Titans don't have the
linebackers I'm afraid of yeah and I do
think that even though guys like Malcom
Butler are really good they let guys get
open deep yeah well yes you're right
they put too much pressure on the
corners and Malcolm Butler I mean again
he got beat deep on a great a perfect
throw last week against Kenny Stills
right he was there I mean his arm is in
the guy's damn many he's still caught it
and ran it but yes I was gonna go more
Josh I'd like to enter a bet of $100 for
the Houston Texans I think it's just it
I like the Titans are a home team that I
think can lose and I think in this game
point and a half's not too much I could
see him winning by a field goal this
might be a left colic come Sunday would
you feel confident I would feel I would
yes yes no start I wish I had a little
machine where I could give you a betting
ticket every time you place a bet
what's a sound for a Titan I don't know
I feel like I'd want to go to that movie
where that guy was like fighting the
Titans and like just find an audio clip
a movie those fighting it or remember
the Rehan dritt something like remember
the time yeah right that's a good movie
never saw on all right moving on to the
Shaw remember the Titans the football
movie you've seen parts of it you've
ever one of the best movies ever I'm
just letting you know sometimes I like
not watching things that people are
obsessed with well I'm not moving on
never intend I've watched a lot I'll be
like great football movies remember the
Titans
yeah Philadelphia on the road at Tampa
Bay the Eagles with the long break here
coming off the Thursday night football
win over the Falcons 18 to 12 tamagawa
step please Tampa Bay obviously coming
off a big win over the Saints last week
forty eight to forty the line were going
with for this game Philadelphia - three
and a half
on the road in Tampa I'd like to clarify
something we're not going with a line it
is behind this is the line that you got
Wednesday night and sent to us we're not
making she I'm not making it up okay it
is the line number one thing I looked at
Ryan Fitzpatrick after big games not
that great like he's just a lot of pics
not a lot of touchdowns just something I
looked at fantasy stuff mm-hmm Mike
Evans interesting Chris Godwin
interesting too Sean Jackson's not
playing if there's one thing that can
happen against this Eagles defense it's
biting on double moves with Jalen Mills
teams look for it and if Mike Evans is
busted off Marshawn Lattimore he's gonna
get one of these guys but I do expect
the Eagles to play a little bit more
zone I felt like the Eagles played a lot
of zone against last week against
Atlanta definitely makes it and they
were very smart on his own cuz they know
how good their dealers actly right
here's the thing that I look at what the
Tampa Bay Vernon Hargreaves is out
uh-huh
Brent Grimes is out huh Nick Foles plays
well in heat he's an Arizona guy he's
played well and every time it was been
hot out there
Johnny weatherman yeah it's a night game
though right no wow you know what I
didn't listen horrea Lauria told me it
was a night game and I just was like
yeah that's a night game who's that one
thing I will say I am worried it's gonna
feel like 97 at kickoff but I'm not
looking at this buck seeing me like oh
wow this is a very long tenured Tampa
Bay team they're all used to the heat
the Bucks have covered their last six as
a home dog and that scares me but in
their last eight games at home in
September there one in seven I wanted to
go with the Bucs here because I said you
know what I could see the Eagles kind of
starting slow [ __ ] that I'm going $50 on
the Eagles - three and a half I'm still
worried about the heat I'm still worried
about a number of things the Eagles have
depth on their D line and they're gonna
get after Ryan Fitzpatrick but I there's
just something about the athletes on
Tampa Bay that if they bust one here and
bust one there that kind of scared me a
little bit and that's why I made it 50
and everyone that listens to our show
knows
I don't like betting a lot of money on
the Eagles because it's gonna make me
feel really bad so I'm only going fifty
yeah okay I get you let me see where did
I start I mean yeah the DeSean Jackson
not being there is huge no doubt about
it the whole offense now comes into it
definitely does it's just one more
favorable matchup that you don't have to
be scared about in your secondary and I
like the way your secondary looked last
week the Philadelphia Eagles and I do
think they'll be smart about how much
they do play man-to-man realizing that
yeah Mike Evans can run by anybody or
beastmode anybody and just Moss someone
OJ Howard Godwin's that good diamond is
extremely good and white boys supreme is
good yes yes yes I mean he's a player
Jimmy Humphries are great no Humphries
ok brakes no brakes that WBS material
quite yet but also the Tampa Bay ol line
as good as it was last week I'm still
not gonna crown it and go I feel
comfortable about it this is a different
animal coming to town it's the freakin
Eagles the heat is something to worry
about
last time the Eagles came at least can I
tell this quick story I don't want to be
when the Eagles came 2006 I lost my
spleen right that was the game or the
surprise man Bruce Craig Kowski played
at the Bruce grad Kowski played but then
that was also Donovan McNabb throwing up
on the field right that was awesome I
mean that was a real thing I've never
seen I remember when the Eagles beat the
Cowboys week 141 to 14 it was the
beginning of Andy Reid being a good
coach 2001 it was the pickle juice game
the entire Eagles team drank pickle
juice to retain liquid to not sweat it
out and the big guy do Staley now
runnings back coach keep an eye if
there's pickle juice on the side on the
sideline the runnings back coach thank
you yeah what is his deal he can't say
running back you do you thought this was
a night game and you're gonna come at me
with runnings but yes but you always
make fun of my English all the time shut
up
okay runnings back coach gonna be a good
either way
missed my battle joke I all set you up
there I did I totally misread you say
when he said batter yesterday no batter
right yes well either the other thing
too is I do think the disability field
up your offense will continue to come
around I do have faith in Doug Peterson
and
Nick Foles won't throw for a hundred and
whatever he threw last week a hundred
and unimpressive yards second least in
the NFL only ahead of the bills yes so I
do think that has to improve at the end
of the day yes I don't trust Fitz magic
and any of that and I am good Josh I
would like to place a hundred dollar bet
on the Philadelphia Eagles
how confident are you in that I'm not
real confident that's why I are matey I
don't think they can shoot down an eagle
my money is blind I got a patch over it
or what does it you'll do I don't even
know what kind of that's a weak Eagle I
think they're a little stronger than I
was at Yellowstone National Park they're
stronger than that that thing right
there on the road to beating the Bucks
okay that's Martellus Bennett hates that
song yeah it's good to know but also
it's a revenge game for Michael Bennett
first drafted by the buck sure they
could end up winning this game by 28
like they obviously could what but I
could also see story of week of the
first two games Tampa Bay beats the
Saints of the Eagles and the heat was a
factor yeah secondary is I mean the
Hargreaves grime grime thing is what
kicks me over the edge with DeSean
Jackson I would go Nelson Aguilar is the
big fantasy player who I like it me
likey moving on next game here the
Kansas City Chiefs on the road at the
Pittsburgh Steelers of course the
Steelers coming off a tie last week 21
21 in Cleveland the Chiefs coming off a
38:28 win over the Los Angeles chargers
the line for this game Steelers - 4 this
is my favorite 1 o'clock game you wanted
to go first or should I oh whatever you
wanted to do I'm gonna go through the
house ok will so we'll go back and forth
um I have so week 2 Tomlin and
Pittsburgh are pretty damn special
alright they six and two in the last
eight years in week two remember last
year they beat the Vikings 26 to 9 I do
remembers the worst game the Vikings had
all year right saw about the Steelers
Tomlin this is what I assumed Tomlin
does they play the first game last year
they barely beat the Browns this year
they tie with the Browns he gets in
there and goes who the hell do you think
you are you know Tomlin yeah and I feel
like he straightens them out
some backup I feel like they're great
again Chiefs are nine and two against
the spread in their last 11 September
road games Steelers are Owen five
against the spread in their last five
home games Kansas City came out Andy
Reed said he's playing the long game
with Eric Barry so I don't expect Eric
Barry to play in this game no this line
started off at Pittsburgh favored by
about six it has now come down to four
there is there are a number of games
that I'm confident in this is one of
them before I saw the spread that I was
already ready to bet on I'm gonna say my
bet right now Josh I'd like to place a
$200 bet on Pittsburgh - for everybody
is talking about Patrick mahomes and the
offense they led up how many points to
the to the Chargers 28 28 points could
have been 45 the Chargers were
completely unorganized I'm seeing there
I'm seeing man-to-man coverage and
they're running all over the place
doesn't even make sense this Steve it
was it's the perfect combination of a
team that I think is being overrated
right now in the Chiefs and a team
that's being severely underrated right
now in the Steelers the Steelers played
at a monsoon there was all these
extenuating circumstances and the fact
that it happened against the Browns
people like it's the Browns you'll see a
little bit later I got a lot of faith in
the Browns I look at the Steelers
I like their offensive line being able
to handle the Chiefs I think they're a
lot but and the Chargers offensive line
I think that Steelers might win this
game by double digits that's how
confident I am in this game III hear you
there
I the first thing to say is yes Kansas
City's writing to you hi everyone's like
stupidly too low and the pittsburgh
steelers stoop I mean Tyra Taylor was 15
for 40 last week they gave that game
away it was a tie and they lost the
turnover battle by five turnovers by
five does anybody like that doesn't
happen you lose by 30 points when you
lose by five turnovers so that tells
also been at home is a different animal
yes and been the criticism of him is
ridiculous
I don't know how sore is elbow is but I
do know
Ben loves to be John Wayne and act like
he's hurt and then come out for 400
hours cuz I'm John Wayne am I too
confident or are you matching my copy so
no I'm a little more scared than you
just because of them a Holmes factor
okay now this is his first road game
like we talked about this Steelers
defense is real the Kansas City
offensive line and their creativity all
right the kids the all the night is
overmatched by by a lot but yes to it in
Hayward TJ watt last week they didn't
have to face Bosa or lino but Reed is
also very good at slowing those things
down you know with the screens of speed
sweeps everything it slows you down from
attacking but I do think at the end of
the day that the Kansas City Chiefs
secondary and defense it's just not
enough for a Pittsburgh I mean are you
kidding me
come on they let up so many yards last
week Orlando Scandrick on whoever he's
covering man-to-man is their fantasy
play I mean that's what I would say I
would just go if you see Orlando
Scandrick on juju or Antonio expect a
big blade on one of those two okay that
would be my thing I was just gonna say
remember Kansas City came in riding high
did that's my night game it was a Sunday
afternoon for a longer game no I'm
talking about last year they came in
like five and oh and then 16 and nine
put up nine points on pitch yes right
it's been a safe place to play yeah that
was in Kansas City last year you're
wrong okay so but either way how'd you
bet i Josh I would like to place $100 on
the Pittsburgh Steelers so what do you
think about my making that a lot i I
don't I I'm with you there that would be
certain this was another game I wanted
to go hard on perfect that's what I want
to hear yeah okay no he goes yeah I just
I just got scared of like I mean Tyree
kill and mahomes and watt Watkins
combination and ruin something well it
could be like it could be like they're
up by 20 in the fourth quarter and he
it's two big bombs and all of a sudden
you go damn it's a six-point game or you
know what I mean that's what scares them
alright totally wussy doubt like left go
style this week and when it's not
listening out it's actually a very
strategic
its strategic you're trying to win here
alright moving on next 1 o'clock game
here the Miami Dolphins coming up to New
York to take on the Jets the
hands coming off a 27-20 in over the
Titans in week one and of course the
Jets on Monday night 48 to 17 over the
Detroit Lions on the road line for this
game is Jets - three Sims we're coming
to you first it's okay here we go
okay the New York Jets great performance
the other night
the Jets defense excuse me yes good old
coffee burn we need to we really need to
clip out every burp burping if anyone
wants to do that we'd love it and we're
gonna put your Twitter handle it's every
episode I know the Jets I don't feel
like it's that kind of burp though it's
just like I'm talking a lot and whatever
I think just happens when you get older
okay maybe a gas just comes officially
old souls in the and earth all thing so
I think hey the Jets defense is good
they got size up front
definitely no one's gonna push they got
good secondary play the linebackers in
the middle of the field are very
athletic I'm very impressed with Avery
Williamson everyone since a baller and
been a baller yeah but like I always
thought he was just a good guy I don't
see no now he's in a system and it's
really impressive the guy that opened my
eyes up to him a few years ago was when
ray Orton was the D coordinator down
there and I had to cover a game for CBS
and he was just like hey you need to
like pay attention to a 'very maybe I'll
ask him a few questions and he was like
he's one of the best players on our team
and I'll get Avery Williamson for the
show wink wink but so there's that sound
okay now let's flip it over to the other
side you didn't talk about the Dolphins
often okay the Dolphins offense I think
is very impressive right now I mean what
they did the game plan wise Albert
Wilson yo Keem gran Kenny Stills got
speed did I say his name wrong I think
it's Chiquita kima might be okay and
then do we know Devante Parker status
what is there here who cares you're
right okay either way and kiseki is a
nice weapon they're using him the right
way their old line is what I was
impressed with last week and Kenyan
Drake is a star and it's a great
two-headed duo with him and Frank Gore
and they're there Ryan Tannehill is not
beating himself and I this is Kennedy
Hill takes the plays that are there yes
and if it's our open receiver downfield
he is
that's what I'm saying it's like two
years ago he was a game manager and
that's when they went to the playoffs
and he's really good at that because
he's got enough feet to roll out and
keep Jack sorry it's okay that's what
you do um then we flipped over the other
side of the ball
hey the Jets offense certainly
impressive there Oh line like we've been
saying is better than what people think
but they also did play the Detroit Lions
last week nothing I mean nothing I mean
come on who you know there's nothing to
write home about with the Detroit Lions
defense in general I mean Ezekiel Lance
has been reduced to nothing ain't
nothing and then so I look at that and I
go this Miami defense is another unit
and in football that I think deserves a
little more respect than people realize
very high on Miami command we we are
high in Miami you know there are sneaky
good on the inside they got a they cover
Quinn exactly Quilliam days Cameron wake
William Hayes wake up my god Shaw's God
Shaw's good let's not forget about
Harris who's their first-round picture
last year their secondary when the cane
and my man Xavier Howard's impressive
and Minka Fitzpatrick is a baller and he
pull out he's a baller
I mean spree safety nickel doesn't
matter let the other safety get that
pick yes Rashad Jones got two picks I
know so uh Josh I would like to place
$100 on the Miami Dolphin interesting
Miami plus three so I went back and
forth with this a million times let me
give Jeff can't shoot down dolphins and
ocean first thing I want to say that I
love when this happens in the NFL when a
storyline links up perfectly
with 15 more yards Frank Gore in the
home of the New York Jets will pass
Curtis Martin for the fourth place
all-time that's on the all-time rushing
list yes which I think will be a very
cool appreciation moment are you gonna
listen to me you both come in your
[ __ ] that was a joke I was not
actually that angry it was actually you
simply to report text you did you
totally scared me I was like wow I was
disrespect no but I think it's gonna be
a really cool moment I would like
hopefully the Jets crowd you know it's a
claim well Frank so liked by everybody
I'm hoping Curtis Martin's there and
they show him on the jumbotron oh that's
tough but he's not as good as Curtis
Martin I just the lines are what really
line it for me for the Jets the last
nine games against the spread the Jets
are seven one and one at home for Miami
in their last 13 games against AFC East
teams against the spread they're 2 and
11 mmm I am going $10 on the New York
Jets minimum bet minimum bet I don't
know what's gonna happen in this game I
like both of these teams I think they're
gonna split the season series I'm gonna
give each of the home teams than not
when they play each other and this week
I'm going with the Jets the one thing
for Miami for Miami last week they were
able to get a lot of turnovers the thing
about Sam Darnell that impresses me the
most other than the pick-6
is his ability to be smart with the ball
yeah and which was a concern coming out
of college yeah which which is very very
funny but I look at the Jets and I go at
home with that defense Miami playing an
eight-hour marathon game there's maybe
they're a little exhausted weird maybe
they have to change their flight pattern
because they're going up the East Coast
or something like that
I just I'm gonna take the whole team and
I'm only putting ten dollars because I
think they're very evenly matched
yeah you're right about that too the
flight pattern what are they gonna do
they gonna like fly to London and then
coming back around that was one thing
that scared me about Carolina Carolina's
having to do like special flight plans
and we always talked I was supposed to
connect to go through there to South
Bend and they had to change my flight
NBC it's just what scares when you talk
about how routine base these
organizations are anytime that happens I
can I ask you this why is it why is it
that climate deniers don't want to
accept science but then when they are
told a us by a scientific machine that
says a huge hurricane goes they go they
listen like well I don't understand it I
just don't understand I just sit there
and go oh I don't think it's really
coming I don't believe in this science
mumbo-jumbo here by the way people that
have beachfront houses not get flood
insurance and then it happens and they
go I want am an idiot I just it's so
annoying
next game here the Los Angeles chargers
on the road visiting the Buffalo Bills
the Chargers coming off a 38 28 loss to
the Chiefs Buffalo coming off a 47 to 3
loss to the Baltimore Ravens 200 and 1
teams line for this game is chargers -
seven point five left go we're coming to
you for Sims we're coming to you first
this game okay where to start here where
to start where to start
okay Buffalo's defense I mean let's make
this quick there's nothing special on
the Buffalo defense really as a whole
today be away sure Jordan ploy the
secondaries nice but there are zone
defense right we know that I love my big
man Edmonds in the middle he's such an
athletic freak certainly okay the real
problem is what their D line what's the
hell are they gonna do are they gonna
pressure Phillip Rivers I don't think so
are they gonna stop the run game that's
pretty damn good by the charges I don't
think so
okay let's flip it around what the hell
are we gonna look at the Buffalo Bills
and go damn okay they're definitely
gonna move the ball up and down this
field there's no chance the Buffalo
Bills win this game in my eyes but Josh
I'm still going to place $100 on the Los
Angeles chargers I also saw I was gonna
go to the curveball there nothing no I
didn't do that yes I'm going with the
Los Angeles chargers here I don't feel
great that's my favorite dance move of
yours you do the Wiggles
wiill Chargers charge lightning kills
Buffalo okay
Tatanka dead to dunk a dead lightning
bolt shot um also no I think this is my
other thing - Josh Allen I know there's
no I know there's no Joey Bosa it
doesn't matter there's just not enough
weapons around him to help him I do
think that they could run the ball maybe
a little bit certainly and the one
o'clock what East Coast game scares me
I did want to go hard on this a few
because yeah I know you wanna I wanted
to but as you know I've chickened out
and I've played smart smart ball there
are short games every year that I look
for right and the early West Coast team
coming to Buffalo at one o'clock as has
names yeah Arizona when they were
undefeated got shellacked I see it every
year Rams go to Buffalo they get beat
West Coast teams in Buffalo at one
o'clock
I love no Bosa no Legion Barksdale might
be out for the church I felt bad man I
saw his knee buckle the Chargers in
their last 25 road games are seven and
18 cheese seven and 18
that's disgusting there's no team that I
think is more inconsistent unreliable
and annoying than the Chargers I am
saying this to everybody I am done
betting on Chargers games the rest of
the year they're not a good football
organization they're not I like Anthony
Lynn I like their players yeah I don't
like their owner Dean Spanos
I feel bad for their fans I think their
stadiums a piece of [ __ ] and I think
overall I don't trust them okay but you
know what I do trust science I would
like to enter the counting of $10 on the
Buffalo Bills to cover the spread for
seven and a half
this will be the headline on Monday
morning pandamonium charger start season
oh and two Super Bowl dream who they are
gonna win the game no probably not
Oh tell against the side it's a betting
order it's a betting newspaper
I I will say this I will say this I
believe that the ball will be in Josh
Allen's hands with a chance to win the
game or tie the game meaning that there
within seven points at the end of this
game
I think LeSean McCoy has a big game I
think these days I mean it's all over
that thing I think that the Chargers
defense was abysmal last week yeah and
again we're all talking about mahomes I
mean if German James didn't dive they
were a lot of 50 points I know
so I I know the Buffalo Bills stink yeah
but I also know that Shaun McDermott is
let's rough him up tough him up coach
yes and I like the fact that they play
zone against the charge yeah okay I know
the Chargers beat up the bills big time
last year I know that but I look at the
bills and I go the football is a
weird-shaped thing and sometimes a team
at this point of the year wins this is
why I was worried about the Bucks that
you go there's no freaking chance
the bills are either gonna win this game
or keep it closed I think they cover the
spread
whoa I know it makes no sense mmm
Tatanka mm-hmm
I crazy right well yeah you're crazy cuz
that mean the Kansas City Chiefs just
got weapons too and I just don't trust
it but okay that's fine that's good I
got I'm glad you did it I just I do bet
on it i $10
oh damn I went for a record no look
because Lefko wants it all to look good
even I got a bank account either I got
it I'm only about the bank account I
don't care about the money I want the
money see this is what's hard for me I
get so excited but then in my pick'em
League I'm gonna pick the Chargers and
then the bills win the game and I'm like
I'm such a wiener yeah you are but do
you can you see my like the NFL is weird
at this point of the year it's the NFL
you know yes this was it after week two
last year we can already see games
that's more the reason why do you
remember that it's part of the reason I
do some of these bet yeah but I can
already see Phil Simms all the analysts
on CBS having charger charger charger
charger right and then that's the image
that goes on Twitter with like Bill
shocking everybody I just I'm feeling it
man
okay alright moving on next game of the
one o'clock the Minnesota Vikings on the
road at Green Bay this week Minnesota
many questions about this game Minnesota
coming off a 24 16 win in week 1 over
the 49ers Green Bay of course Sunday
night football against the Packers I've
said of course for every score that I've
read so far on this podcast the line for
this games is a business but line for
this game is a pick'em and injury
updates left go as you referenced
Davante Adams gonna be limited in
today's practice holders - older Aaron
Rodgers still questionable not expected
to practice on Thursday no and did you
see his quote about wanting to play all
right yeah I'm wanting to play but how
he ended it they're like are you worried
that you're not gonna be able to
practice at all and he was like nope he
doesn't need to practice I wish she did
the ivory I know practice but ok um man
top one here in Green Bay dirt certainly
an advantage for Green Bay being at home
it slows down the Minnesota Vikings
because Green Bay's on grass seven-foot
high grass yes it's not Chicago along
but it definitely changes the style of
the football game and especially for a
team like Minnesota that's built to play
on that indoor turf and be fast and be
chaotic I think I worry about Minnesota
with that interior front and if there's
a strength to this the Packers defense
it's their interior 3 they got some big
mofos in the middle of there yeah and
they can cause some havoc in that run
game for the Minnesota Vikings here's my
biggest concern in the match of course
Aaron Rodgers I do expect to play
Davante Adams man if he doesn't play
they're in deep trouble I mean big
trouble little China like tiny tiny
little China it's big trouble ok this is
the my big narrative though Minnesota
can Rodgers wants to throw the ball
quick right this week's you don't want
to get the bottom his hands quickly are
gonna be all over they're gonna put they
can play man-to-man and bump and run and
Rodgers might not be able to throw the
ball quick in time so he's gonna go damn
I mean Xavier Rhodes is all over Randall
Cobb I can't throw this ball oh damn
you know Mike Hughes is all over
Geronimo Allison I can't throw this ball
and I just think that's enough time
digging for that pass rush to get there
i josh would like to place $100
bet on the purple people eaters rally
the troops we must take on the Parkers
of Green Bay ascend on them I'm taking
Minnesota did you have any Viking in
your blood
Nordic a little bit but not as much as I
thought do you want to just know it do
we really want to talk about this like
really not talked about on a Monday show
yes I think we do yeah okay I want to
take like a solid ten minutes okay
all right last five games against the
Packers the Vikings are foreign one of
the one fantasy guy that I would really
recommend would be Jimmy Graham I know
we didn't do well last week very good
point there was one position that did
well against Minnesota last week it was
George kid all right
and I could see tight ends being a
factor one thing can I just say real
quick before I started the oh [ __ ] play
and football last week I half the league
ran at last st everybody rolls to the
right the tight end right they like fake
the zone to the right with two tight
ends over there and it looks like the
tight ends and then he goes back I mean
there was so many teams as I watched him
I was like damn there it is again
they sharply ssin 4:30 sorry good it was
great yeah I went back and forth about
this a lot and picking the Packers
doesn't make sense you look at them a
banged up Aaron Rodgers a banged up wide
receiver but you know what Josh I'd like
to put $10 on the Green Bay Packers
because that it's a game at home and
it's Aaron Rodgers and if he plays I
want Aaron Rodgers my big thing was this
I think it the Vikings offense from what
you said is where I got scared yeah
because I have a feeling that Kirk
Cousins and those guys are gonna have a
very tough sledding in Green Bay and I
see a lot more athletes on the back end
of granny Bay's defense than they do
have in San Francisco and I think that
they're gonna jump a lot of route just
familiarity and all that and I just
think that the Packers offensive line is
it's a lot better than the 49ers
offensive line and Aaron's gonna make
some stuff happen he's our Savior for a
reason and it's a pick'em and if you're
gonna ask I Minnesota makes the most
sense there are a much better defense
but I'm calling Packers all right cool
I'm just riding I'm a tu I don't totally
agree with you that their offensive line
is much better than the 49ers you don't
think so no I don't I said so it's at
home Vikings is a different team than on
the road bike I I felt the same way
about this one that I felt about jets
Miami so either way I was going $10 I go
I'm just gonna put on the home team yeah
cool last game in the one o'clock slate
here guys Cleveland at New Orleans
Cleveland the 21 21 tie against
Pittsburgh last week the Saints oh and
one after a 4840 loss to Tampa Bay line
for this game Saints - 8.5 Sims we're
going to you first we're going to let's
go Sims a bet yo-yo and it's leet some
gumbo cuz it's good down there okay
crocodile cheesecake so totally off off
here okay either way let's just get into
this Cleveland Browns the defense is
very good it really is there's no
denying it I don't know if it's good
enough to totally slow down this
offensive attack for the New Orleans
Saints I mean in the world in Saints
were not stopped one time last week they
they didn't keep pace because Michael
Thomas fumbled the ball and Gillis Lee
fumbled the ball or that game might have
been a 51 48 New Orleans win they're a
machine they're at home they're good
enough on the offensive line that
Cleveland will not steamroll them and I
still don't think Cleveland has enough
good cover guys to totally ruin the New
Orleans Saints okay now on the other
side of the ball the Browns offense is
still concerning I'm not sure if they
can run the ball effectively it's a
question I have on the new world I mean
against the New Orleans Saints I have a
question about that I don't know if they
can do that and the past game hey
they're gonna have some matchups the
Saints like to play man too much man and
you know guys like Josh Gordon they
scare me and that kind of matchup yes
joke who scares me
you know we'll see you with Jarvis
Landry again I think we're gonna start
to see that Jarvis Landry can't always
get open against man-to-man coverage
he's better once you get the ball into
his hands right but
either way I think the way I look at it
is like this Cleveland is a solid
football team and I got questions about
the Saints defense and if they are too
aggressive to play man-to-man and oh
okay we're gonna throw up jump ball to
to Gordon or a Jarvis Landry and I don't
know that there's enough physical freaks
on the front for the Saints right now to
always contain Tyrod Taylor from when he
runs and moves so Josh I mean with too
long there but I would like to place
$100 bet on the Cleveland Browns I think
they will lose the football game I don't
care if you're religious or not I'll
bite you'll learn but yes I I do think
they're gonna keep it close they lose
the game but keep it somewhat close six
point loss something like that number
one New Orleans is gonna be studying
tape of Cleveland and it's gonna be
monsoon tape and I find that to be an
advantage for Cleveland the fact that
you can't study film of them on a normal
surface I think that helps them hmm I
went back and looked Greg Williams
facing his old head coach Sean Payton
last time they faced Saints rolled the
Rams 49:21 he dropped 49 points and his
old DC just something to keep in mind
yes fantasy wise which is so funny cuz
he hired him from when he was at the
Rams because he gave him a hard time and
then he got him and he didn't like go
and now use them but guy fantasy wise I
really like Ben Watson Cleveland gets up
gives a lot of points to tight ends
because they play their safeties too far
back yes so Ben Watson will be my guy
there as I've said last week New Orleans
has started the last four years
oh and two they started this year oh and
one here comes the second game the last
five games between the New Orleans
Saints and the Cleveland Browns against
the spread Cleveland is four and one I
remember a close one in Cleveland I do
remember go ahead Saints yeah play the
Bucs last week
Ryan Fitzpatrick didn't just throw the
ball well Sims what else did he do
really well ran well and I would argue
that Tyrod Taylor is a much better
runner than Ryan Fitzpatrick
I would like to bet $50 Josh on the
Cleveland I thought to go really strong
I was like wow okay I would like to go
$50 on the Cleveland Brown let's go
spread his money out this week I am a
firm believer though I think that
Cleveland might win this game hmm
I think that the Saints and the Chargers
your two possible Super Bowl picks it I
could see them losing to Cleveland and
Buffalo which is a wild thing to say
right but the disrespect to Cleveland
that they're eight and a half point dogs
that they're still Cleveland I know
their offense wasn't good yeah but the
same way I feel about the Steelers being
underrated because they played in the
monsoon that's how I feel about
Cleveland - okay I look at the Saints
defense and I go oh they're just gonna
turn it on right like they let up 40
points it's just gonna turn it on next
week no they will not no they will not
and I think Cleveland has a pretty good
offensive line I worry about that rookie
left tackle that they're playing or
right tackle whatever it is but overall
I know you think Cleveland's gonna win I
think they could okay but I think in my
pool I'm probably gonna pick the Saints
yeah but I think they're definitely
gonna cover yeah I did yeah
I just think the Saints are notoriously
slow starters it's another team that
they might overlook and miles Garrett is
gonna be in Drew Brees his face I don't
know I don't know I don't know either
I got Cleveland's a heart it's a hard
gauge cuz the game last week they should
have lost by 14 points last week moving
on to the four o'clock games here guys
well it's a win the game I do yes that I
I'm with you I bet more money for them
to cover the spread four o'clock game
here Detroit at San Francisco LA coming
off a Monday Night Football loss on the
short week to the Jets San Francisco
lost week one 24 16 against the Vikings
line for this game is the 49ers minus 6
all right I'm gonna go first on this one
things that I really like and the reason
that I will be putting my money on the
49ers straight up in the last 12 games
on the road against the Niners what do
you think the Lions record is in the
last 12 on the road against the 49ers
I'm gonna say two and ten oh and twelve
oh and they lose by an average margin of
nearly fourteen points holy crap the
Lions are eight and 21
in their last 29 road games in September
there are two and thirteen straight up
in their past 15 games on the west coast
and they played on Monday Night Football
Josh I'd like to bet 150 dollars on the
Niners - six Sims yeah I mean Matt
Stafford doesn't look like he's gonna be
a hundred percent
Ezequiel ons is banged up is a Shaun
Robinson gonna dress there's multiple
reports of the team hating their coach
no doubt about it he's got to get them
spurred up at a short week I think
there's definitely that's a real report
that's not just like hearsay I think
there's a lot of people in Detroit that
don't like Matt Patricia right now I
think that San Francisco could have
easily won that football game in
Minnesota and now it's gonna be a team
that's gonna go man we messed that up
Kyle and Jimmy G are gonna be on a
mission to [ __ ] on whoever's in their
way a hundred percent and I am going to
Josh I would like to place a hundred
dollars on the San Francisco 49ers that
feels like that should be a left Cola I
think so I would say so yes
I mean what's the fear Matt Stafford
goes off that's it but I don't know if
that's gonna happen this year because I
don't think they're playing through Matt
Stafford I think that's one of the
problems with Matt Stafford right now
they're also doing the same thing that
was the problem with the Eagles offense
in the beginning of the year last year
where every time they put LeGarrette
Blount out there yeah and so for an
offense it completely throws everything
off yeah they're trying to be this like
carrier Johnson's New England offense a
team and they're not built to be the
carry on Johnson's not the guy yet no
he's not there yet
no I don't even know if he fits that run
scheme what they're trying to do carry
on Johnson's like a levy on bail you
need to give him the zone scheme that's
what the Pittsburgh does and then he
picks the hole they're trying to do
pulling guards man-to-man blocking hit
the hole hard that's not am I worried
about here I don't know you're right I'm
just I I worry about Matt Stafford I
think you're good I mean if I was gonna
go a left go lock I think that would be
one of mine - okay yeah it makes hats
one of the ones I have the most money
let's see what's there such a way it
doesn't really matter I was gonna say
what's their injury update what their
offensive line the 49ers they're
questionable right
person and Garnett and Garnett toe
injury for Garnett I believe okay damn
all right but it doesn't change me it's
not like that deeper just say they were
able to really battle with the Vikings
and have multiple drives and inside the
five I learned over he can hide other
now he just watched he just watched
Detroit on tape not cover the middle of
the field right like oh you're not gonna
cover the middle of field against a Kyle
Shanahan offense yeah Pierre Garcon
George kiddo like me up next four
o'clock game Cardinals in Los Angeles to
take on the Rams spread for this game is
Rams - 13 Rams - 13 I look at this and I
think what people need to realize are is
that the home-field advantage for LA is
not that good against the spread since
2016 since returning to the Coliseum the
Rams are 410 and one the Cardinals are
eight and one in their last nine games
against the division rival on the road
the Cardinals are four and one against
the spread their last five games on the
road against the Rams the Rams straight
up three and nine in their last 12 games
in week two it is a short week for the
Rams I want to say though the Rams they
beat no one worse than the Cardinals
last year beating them in those two
games by a combined score of 65 to 16 I
thought that Alex Smith and Washington
protect the ball perfectly they milked
the clock in the first half but I
thought Arizona came back in the second
half and I thought their offense was
pretty darn good against that Washington
team I know the Rams are special I know
they're good but this is what I thought
I thought they were gonna blow away the
Seahawks last year early on and the
Seahawks beating like 9 to 3 or that was
two years ago it's a short week for the
Rams last year I am gonna go Arizona to
cover the 13 but I'm only putting ten
dollars on a Josh I'm taking the 13
points there but for $10 I just think
that there's something about the Rams at
home against divisional teams that weird
I mean yeah there is no home-field
advantage I think I just look at the
Cardinals offense which has a better old
line this year I mean they're not like
devastated there
I just have no faith in this scheme I
really don't that's what bothers me a
whole lot and then when you have a
scheme with no weapons that really scare
you on the outside like the Kirk kids a
good player don't get me wrong but he
needs other people so does Larry exactly
there are really is slot receivers there
they are
so that scares me against this group I
agree okay then I flip over on the other
side no I'm being crazy it's not crazy I
mean 13 points is a lot in the NFL
especially in week two it's a lot um you
know hey the Rams yeah you know this is
still your they're going they're
watching Carolina Panther film right
that's what people got to realize he's
watching last week's Arizona game
against the Redskins and he's gonna
watch Carolina from last year because
that's where Steve wolf came from so
that's always a little weird too but I
mean it's the master game planner
against the defensive coach who's a good
defensive coach but doesn't blow you
away with creativity it's more about
just being sound doing your job I mean I
think Gurley could have a hundred and
fifty rush that's that's what I I think
- so Josh at the end of the day I would
like to place $100 bet on the Los
Angeles Rams
I just can't back the Cardinals yet I
just really can't and I don't even think
the Rams played math where are you
little cardinal [ __ ] run you over
back but the eye I don't even think the
Rams play their best game last week and
they still won by 20 yeah so that's
where I look at it like they struggled
and then once they got going and I think
I think there are a talented football
team I don't think the Cardinals keep
this close I just for me it's me keep it
close for a while and they just get run
out as you can tell I am picking a chaos
week - I just think a lot of the teams
it's just so you're going with human I'm
like human elements let down and stuff
like that Arizona I feel like they're
gonna they're gonna be super pissed and
they're going to a division rival where
they've had success before and I also
think that I look at Goff and I go Mac I
see Pat Pete picking them off and taking
it to the house yeah and if one of those
things happens now the Rams gotta beat
him by 20 you know what I mean like 13
such a big number that like if the
Cardinals start off with a David Johnson
touchdown
you got out score me by 20 the rest of
the way damn my wife is sending me a
picture like they have a kitten and she
goes he needs a home like why are they
near a kitten I they went to a shelter
why did they go to the shelter I don't
know their cat why not
you got the whole animal kingdom there
what's that one of my cats left who left
knee juice juice left do said dude
cousin Nevis drove him out of the house
he looked back and said he got worse
pics and left go get out of here
damn tell your wife no should I time
they brought the damn cat oh I get a cat
damn okay I don't know what the hell all
right speaking of the Rams todd gurley
loves cats more than dogs me too moving
on cats animals on the planet greatest a
dozen plant your cats are cool I don't
normally like cats cat all right before
we go to the Nevis so you have a cat
that came from the island of Nevis it's
kind of weird per right you do it really
and he's psycho I mean he's got one eye
cuz he got his face broken by hitting by
a car
but you can talk to him I mean my little
girl I'm sure I can talk to ya and that
is Chris seems doing an impersonation of
his cat Nevis then I have roll and then
I have Rome Rome's really cause she's
like she tries to talk to you she's
really smart that sounds like blues she
tries to talk it's really amazing cats
were the greatest animals on the planet
you guys good yeah good let's move on
speaking of cats Oh 25 a rematch of last
year's AFC Championship game the New
England Patriots on the road in
Jacksonville visiting the Jaguars lion
for this game is New England minus 1.5
in the deep Sims breakdown on this okay
here we go it's a go uh um okay
hey Jacksonville we know they're super
talented we know what they can do on
that defensive side of the football what
always scares me when anybody plays New
England Patriots when you play the same
scheme too much
they're just magicians I mean hey Tom
Brady threw for what 400 yards against
the Seattle Seahawks defense in their
prime in 2014 same exact defense this
Jaguars defense might be more talent
then that Seattle defense I'm not gonna
deny that but this is four years later
where there's just more an inventory on
this scheme altogether
that scares me in this matchup added to
the fact that I think the Patriots oline
is pretty damn good
they ain't gonna run over a big brown on
the left side that guard Center plays
pretty damn good and they can run the
ball and keep you honest and yes there's
no huge weapons in the past game that
necessarily scare you other than Gronk
and they might go oh wow that's what I
wanted to get into you wanna talk about
Jalen Ramsey oh he might cover a
Gronkowski you're right that's right oh
and he might slow them down certainly
but damn you have to use your best
corner on a 270 pounds six seven tight
end and what happens is Oh Danny
Amendola goes off in the AFC
Championship game the ripple effect is
what kills you when you have to do this
so of course New England's offense and
McDaniels were amazing its Brady and
he's awesome and he can dissect you then
let's flip it over real quick New
England's defense is more equipped to
handle Jacksonville Jaguars this year
than they were in the AFC Championship
game the front seven is bigger and more
physical they are not gonna have to
commit the resources to stopping Leonard
fournette who doesn't sound like he's
gonna be a hundred percent or play at
all but they're not gonna have to be as
worried about being bullied by that
Jaguar deal on New England's healthy up
front guys like Danny Sheldon Lawrence
guy Hightower JaJuan Bentley that middle
linebacker they will not be bullied by
this Jacksonville offensive line when
they don't have to commit more resources
to stopping that run they then can Billy
ball game can be Billy Brainiac and come
up with a lot of different ways to messy
like my Billy's the ball game Billy
bargain and Billy brandy yes now he can
come up with a lot of different ways to
take away the screens from brute Blake
bortles
the bootlegs from Blake bortles which is
hard to defend when you're getting your
ass whooped in the run game which I
don't think happens so because of that
Josh I would like to place $100 on the
New England Patriots that's great I got
another nickname for Billy's about to
get his ass beat I'd like to bet $10 on
Jacksonville
oh you got strong left go big tough guy
uh it's gonna be a little rainy it's
gonna be 96 degrees
I love the Patriots when they have to go
down to Miami they always seem to lose
those games everything you're saying
makes sense in fact every gambling piece
of advice the Patriots are the greatest
road favorite like ever like it's it's
insane when they're a favor on the road
they always win I just can't get out of
my mind all of the little pluses they
got against the Texans last week that
I'm hoping they don't get this week yeah
here's a fumble on the first play the
the the the way they beat out the NFL to
get that touchdown at the end before the
challenge the Gronkowski thing I look at
the Giants been throwing a stupid so
upset that they lost in the AFC
Championship game I think for the first
time in a long time that place is gonna
be juice yeah I like the home dog
I think Jacksonville all the things you
said about scheme if there's one team
that might be too good for other
people's schemes it might be Jack's no
doubt about that do I really believe in
the jack I'm I'm just gonna I think that
Jacksonville I might be Owen to picking
Jacksonville games this year but I just
think they're gonna be emotional I think
they're gonna go in there and I think I
think Brady might get popped a few times
at least I'm gonna say this hmm
I'm hoping Brady gets popped of it I'm
not saying I don't like Brady I'm just
tired of clean-sheet Brady yeah I just
have and I'm hoping that some people
figure out that the Patriots only do
three step drops and get it out right
away and the jaguars can be all over it
and they're not afraid of getting beat
deep if there are really three step drop
I know but if they have a quick passing
game they have smart ways that I said
one team that has multiple guys that can
guard Grunk
it's the Jacksonville Jaguars so I'm
just not forgetting that they were
beating the Patriots by 10 points with
eight minutes left and they had the ball
and miles Jack wasn't down and I just
think it's an emotional thing and I
think they're gonna go out there and I
think they're gonna punch you in the
mouth cool I really hope so I can't wait
for that game left go today has Williams
asked oh I've never seen him go so hard
motion
right he's gonna break his own damn
fingers here in seconds I really are
predicting a chaotic week I'm gonna go
like four and twelve do you know that
I'm tied for the lead remember that
there's a website pic watch I'm tied for
the lead with like Bill Cowher which
makes me not feel good about my thing
that's good what they like pickin
against the spread or a website that
tracks all the NFL analysts across the
country how the most incredible thing is
not my record it's the fact that I'm now
being watched by the pic watch website
because remember that year I started off
fifteen and one in week one yeah and I
was furious that I wasn't on there and
then I had to realize that you were the
people you were the reason that people
listened to the show I'm on the pic
match welcome to the big the down road
I'm scared for the downward spiral over
the next two weeks if oh why did they
put me on there no I left goal ah that's
why I'm honestly saying I'm gonna come
back four and twelve I'm way to KY
really hopes up all right
next for 25 games away do you like my
shirt I do my Terrell Owens posing on
the star I bought this from Terrell
Owens website good for you and he said
thanks man thanks man it's a good DN
Thank You Terrell Terrell Terrell right
for 25 the Oakland Raiders visiting the
Denver Broncos spread for this game
Denver minus five and a half I'm gonna
go first this is one of my big bets of
the we first thought I wrote down I like
Denver then I went in the last six times
that Raiders have played in Denver
Denver has not only won they've also
covered the spread I told you the record
first two weeks of the year if they play
in Denver what's their record thirty two
and three they did it last week they're
gonna do it again Raiders in their last
six game
the Broncos are 12 and OH in their last
12 home games in September Oakland is
going out there and signing martavis
Bryant defensive linemen who are
probably not in the same game shape as
they should be
now clan MacDonald and McDonald and so
that was the other one they signed on a
big one Jonathan hang on they're
probably not in game shape definitely
don't worry
you have to go to Denver in high
altitude and run case keenum looked good
last week it's a short week for an older
team playing in Denver and they're tired
and you know Denver is gonna get up and
what's the one weakness of the Oakland
offensive line tackles the tackles von
Miller the only thing I'm afraid of is
the Raiders interior line pushing the
crap out of Denver and Marshawn Lynch
getting a 14 nothing lead I don't think
you got to worry about that good I am
going Josh $300 on Denver minus five and
a half oh that's the big one
damn you're gonna make me root for John
Gurdon hard how dare thy do you agree
with what I'm saying I do agree I'm
betting $100 Josh on the Denver Broncos
and that um yeah where you say like
agreeing with me yeah what are the
things that scare that should scare me
for making that bet that I don't think
it was as bad as it looked last week for
the Oakland Raiders no of course you
know I mean just think about this they
had the ball ten to seven on the 19 yard
line going in to score and he threw it
to an open receiver and it should have
been a touch those at home I know I get
you I know I'm I'm with you so don't
[ __ ] sitting there agreeing with you
those are just the things I literally
ask you what should scare know and then
I tell them it is like how dare you tell
me that so keep telling me the scary
that that does scare me you know the run
game thing to a degree but not really
Denver's big in the middle they got a
lot of a guys I remember in the
preseason you were like I don't know
what they are and yeah well they're
they're they're defense yeah I wasn't
sure exactly what they're I'm not
worried about their personnel up front
though that's ok I mean they got the
peco's the God says my man Walker from
Florida State last year right Shelby
Harris's impressive Zach Kerr so when
they want to play big boy football they
can do that also what you said about the
pass rushers I mean Shane ray look good
Von Miller looked like the superstar
that signed 100 million dollar contracts
as Mike my favorite yeah Chubb
is again maybe not living up to the
billing right now but certainly a really
good strong quality outside linebacker
defense and /type okay
I look at that I wasn't overly overly
impressed with the Oakland Raiders
offense a game plan or just their their
overall scheme and I think this is the
big thing that I think is getting lost
in the shuffle the best offensive
coordinator the Oakland Raiders have had
the last ten years is the offensive
coordinator for the Denver Broncos
revenge coordinator game like Bill
Musgrave because he's a nice guy and
he's quiet Musgrave vasotec car was up
for the m/v exactly right he's one of
those guys that he doesn't play the
political game he doesn't try to get his
face out there
it's my minovsky theory against the
Colts I love people like don't give him
credit his heir offense he is Bill
Musgrave I'm not telling you he's
McDaniels Shanahan McVeigh Sean Payton
but he's that next group a giant Rudin
yeah I would even say he's above Jay
Gruden I would yes he's he has got
everything in his offense along with you
read or write it being that class of
guys exactly a good class it is a good
class no doubt about it so I think when
I look at it from that aspect and Case
Keenum through some dumb interceptions
last week I think he'll learn from them
yes and like again the radar secondary
are we scared of something there I think
Emanuel Sanders is gonna pop off again
the d-line thing is a concern but I
don't know if Denver's run game is quite
good enough to really abuse it the way
it should I don't think they can but I
don't see it's exactly but still they're
the better team and I'm with you with
the Broncos um five and a half's not too
much I don't think so no and I also
think this we went back and watched the
punts from Michael dicks holy crap and
the Seahawks against the Broncos and
when you realized that he was guys we're
not even kidding
I mean he's punting from his own 15 and
he's putting it out of bounds on the
five like that's unreal and so when you
realize that the Broncos were we're
doing that and and that's not gonna
happen against the Raiders market king
is punting for the Broncos against his
former team hey very excited for when he
points over at the sidelines and calls
out Gruden at the end during the game
that's money Sunday Night Football
NFC matchup and if see East matchup in
Dallas
Giants at Cowboys line for this game
Dallas - three Gophers
okay sure um Dallas scares me the
offensive line lacked lack I mean the
the offensive lack of creativity is
scary to me okay I think that's the
first thing I look at I do think the
offense will be better this week because
I think like the Jones family has
already told us they'd like to run dak
more you're gonna see quarterback design
runs and I'm letting us know the game
plan Jeff Jones family I mean so that's
one thing I look at okay I do think
that's gonna help it out Ezekiel element
and his run game I don't think that
they're gonna be able to blow the Giants
off the ball in any capacity because the
Giants are really big up front but I
still do think this is a very good
offensive line and they should be able
to run the ball if they have a little
schematic will help to keep the Giants
honest but again the same problem is Eli
Apple Jenkins they're gonna be able to
cover anybody on the field for the
Dallas Cowboys that's concerning and
then I look at the other side of the
ball and go man the Giants whole line of
a shaky against the Jaguars last week
it's gonna be a blessing in disguise
this week
Dallas is d-line is the real deal
Holyfield but they're not the
Jacksonville Jaguars and they're a
little banged up they are a little
banged up you concussion so I think in
the fact that the Giants got to see a
team like Jacksonville last week it's
only gonna help them to go wait okay
there this guy groups good but they're
not Jacksonville and we got our feet
underneath them and I do think Shermer
will come up with enough of creative
plan to get Odell sake on the ball all
of that so Josh I would like to place a
hundred-dollar bet on the New York
Football Giants there were two lines
that when I saw I went that doesn't make
sense
one was Atlanta being favored by six
hefter just lost in Kiana Neal Indiana
Jones the other was Dallas being favored
in this game by three I was worried that
after playing on national television
last week against the Panthers that this
line would swing the other way people
seem to forget that the Giants played
the Jaguars and the Jaguars were the
most talented team in the NFL have
forgotten that I know it's crazy the
Cowboys are eight and 17 against the
spread in their last 25 as a home
favorite I believe they're gonna be
eight and 18 Josh I'd like to bet $300
on the New York Giants
one simple for this reason I'm gonna get
a big sake one play I'm gonna get a big
Odell play you're telling me that Carole
that the Cowboys are gonna be able to to
march down and score 21 points the
Giants are so thrilled that dak is gonna
run and that Sikhs gonna run because
that's a part of their defense that's
great
Leonard fournette couldn't get it going
I don't think Zeke's gonna get it going
the Jacksonville offensive line
currently is better than the Cowboys
offensive line there's no receiver that
I think they're gonna I could see jinora
Jenkins getting another surprise pick
Eli's gonna have more time in the pocket
I think that Shermer is a better coach
than all of the coaches on the Cowboys
currently right now I like Jason Garrett
but they're up against it there's so
much pressure on the Cowboys to get it
working right the Giants are pissed the
Cowboys are nervous it's different it's
different I think that the Giants are
gonna Jason Garrett's coaching for his
job schirmer's coaching to put you into
the ground yeah I look at the Giants and
I think they're severely underrated
right now I think people still think
that Jaguar stink probably because I
think Blake bortles stinks but I look at
this game and I go I think the Giants
win this game by double digits
I really do I think that in the
beginning of the game I think dak has
like a rushing touchdown and maybe the
Cowboys jump out to a fast start
I really do write but I don't like their
kicker I don't like most of their team I
don't like this new guard Connor
Williams just yet I think it's really
early I don't know if Olivia Vernon
place and if he does I'd like the Giants
even more I just look at the Giants and
I go I think they've had our football
team I really do I think they're - yeah
I get you what do you think about them
is a love Cola it's a little scary
I am only scared cuz of one reason Zeke
no Eli Manning exactly mmm this is the
worst quarterback I mean if he gets here
hit a few times and starts to have
people around him just like we saw last
week it scares me from that so that's
where all my only flaw would be that
that we saw Nate's older we
Hernandez and Eric flowers play like
they did last week and now Eli gets the
snap and he likes to he'll look at the
rush for a second and then he misses
what he needs to throw downfield but
that's not my only concern I agree with
everything so my two biggest bets yeah
let me know what you think yeah I took
this is why I was laughing earlier about
being afraid of divisional matchups
there were divisional matchups I put the
most money on but Giants at Dallas
getting three and we I know we have a
Monday night and guarantee to Lou and
GERD you to lose and Denver at home
hosting Oakland do you like though do
you were you thinking about putting more
money on those games because you did
agree with me yeah I think I was with
you with Denver you're not that with me
with I'm just scared of the Giants I
don't know cuz Dallas is just in Dallas
they're such an energy team it just
scares me I think the Giants are gonna
win the football game don't get me wrong
for me it came down to playmakers yeah I
think it's a fair thing and and the
thing is is Odell looked amazing yeah
and say Kwan look they're only gonna
look better they're exactly they're only
gonna look better they're gonna be more
in shape you gotta remember that guys
like sake wanna know del didn't do [ __ ]
all preseason so they're actually gonna
be in better well social shape and
everything but I looked at Zink and Zeke
looks slower I I would agree Zeke did
look a step slow to me and and so I
think the Giants like I could see Landon
Collins everywhere so we'll say yeah
yeah alright guys last game of the week
here Monday Night Football Seattle on
the road in Chicago this game the Bears
are heavily three-point all boys to win
the East the Bears are a three point
favorite on Monday Night Football yeah
we [ __ ] yeah let me actually before we
get to that I want to read this text
from my dad this morning Bruce Bruce I
said the cow I said I think the Giants
are gonna beat the Cowboys he goes I
agree the Cowboys could come in last
place in the East and I jokingly texted
him can't believe you convinced me to
pick them and he goes you committed a
violation I hope you learned from this
and never repeat it and I laughed he
goes mom and I were discussing the
adjustment of your inheritance
due to this violation I love it how much
is Bruce worth they're just gonna leave
alright I'm gonna go first here Seattle
Chicago Monday Night Football since 25
and 1 to make me the executor of her
will at one point and Wendy Wright I
love
and she walked into my dad's house and
she's like you know I think I'm gonna
make Christopher the executor of my will
and my dad pause for a second and and
then she then she goes she goes well
maybe I should make it for you and give
you the first billing and and let you be
the executor and I'll make Christopher
the second you know and my dad pause for
a second and he looked at her he goes
how much you worth I might throw your
ass in the lake right now feed you the
swans dad what was the name of the bird
the Hooper the Hooper oh we were talking
about it this morning we couldn't
remember the Hooper mess of the Hooper
holy crap since 2016 when the Bears are
an underdog at home their record against
the spread eight and one and one they
love being underdogs at home Seattle on
the road in their last 13 games against
the spread for seven and two hmm I could
not hurt a little bit yeah it's a baby
burp but I ate food
I did too I could not believe the Bears
were not six-point favorites in this
cave okay the fact that they're three
it's it's as if people forgot the first
half all we're talking about is how bad
Mitchell Tripp risky was and the defense
letting up those points to Rodgers but
if you look at your first I saying if
you think your Biscay was bad yes if you
look back at the first half Navy's
offense was incredible the defense was
great the Seattle Seahawks offensive
line that right tackle going up against
Khalil Mack yeah Russell Wilson is going
up against a better defense this week
that he went up against last week yes
not even close I'm not gonna say not
even close but I do think this defense
is better I'm willing to say nothing
okay I have $100 on the Bears minus
three Josh if you could put that in
there for me thank you one more time I
just I look at the Bears and I think
that they're I think they're a team
that's gonna be super motivated
especially after what happened last week
I think that crowds gonna be super
pumped they will be and
is Russell Wilson's great but he's we
say that Rodgers doesn't by himself
Russell's are really good doing about a
lot by and Doug Baldwin's out I like
Tyler Lockett as a three right not a
great fan of him as a one yeah are you
so I'm going bears hundred dollars again
Sims alright so um okay first thing is
like you said this bears defense it is
better than the Broncos I'm not gonna
say it's significantly better I think
it's a more creative scheme to though so
that's we're gonna be more annoying for
the Seattle Seahawks
I wouldn't you say though that the
interior guys for the Bears are yeah
yeah team Hicks right any Goldman's me
and guys have the edge guys as a total
might be better to I mean I'm saying
yeah I I totally hear that and the
linebackers right for but I don't know
if they can play as well man-to-man as
like pac-man Harris and Bradley Roby but
still a good secondary and Kendall
fuller I always get watch once on the
Bears Kendall or Kyle Kyle is awesome um
so I look at that and what we always
talk about in Chicago like Russell
Wilson magic time is gonna be hard
that's the longest grass in the sport
they're gonna make sure it's a little
longer so you can't run around - okay so
that scares me yes that off I like the
Seahawks offense better than years past
like I've told you he liked the scheme
the scheme is better there was more
creative things going on in that Denver
Bronco game they made some big plays
that tight end dis lis or whatever the
rookie he's impressive okay okay Kris
Carson just a good job Rashad Penny's
not ready for big-time yet he's not in
shape because he missed too much time um
so I look at that I do like the Seattle
offense like I said but I don't know if
there's enough there the other side of
the ball
Mitchell drew risky played fine last
week okay it's very hard when you're up
by 22 nothing it wasn't just Mitchell
crew Biscay who became he became
conservative he and I want to go mid
that his coaches go
be careful we're up by 20 and we have a
great defense those are things that
sometimes get said and now the the
quarterback becomes [ __ ] because
he's afraid to disappoint his head coach
and also Matt Nagy became conservative
to go along with that
I don't think that happens this week
Green Bay their second there what do I
want to say here with Green Bay
secondary or green baize defense right
is much better than Seattle's TV it is
definitely in the scheme is way more
complex say your Shakima Griffin thing
shaking Griffin is getting benched
because he blew up I mean the Ryan
Lindsay touchdown to the left sideline
when he caught it
that was cover for chicane Griffin was
supposed to be out there he stayed
inside and took the bait and a receiver
and then it was free running chickie he
did not have a good game he was a little
bit of too much of the Tasmanian Devil
in this game and all over the place and
not in the right place so they are it
sounds like I love Lindsey they're gonna
Bend him yeah those combine Phillip
Lindsay and Ryan Lindley I did I think
you're and then so that was my point
there that the Chicago offense I think
is going to be better this week because
Seattle's defense is not as talented as
Green Bay let alone they play the same
scheme almost the whole game right so
that aspect of it like Green Bay in the
second half Mike Patton they did some
creative crap like where I was like ooh
good job passing off crossers and they
were all over it there so I look at it
that way it's gonna frustrate Seattle
even more Chicago is very loud like you
said they are gonna be pumped Khalil
MCEs in town they're so excited they
Knight Fisher the one last week Josh I'd
like to bet $100 on the Bears there it
is all right so our our late for 4
o'clock game Sunday night game Monday
night game we we both wet Denver giant
Chicago do you want to go over our big
disagreements yes so the big
disagreements from this week first one
was Colts at Redskins Sims you went with
the Colts left go you went with the
Redskins Knicks moving down the line
here Miami at the Jets Sims you went
Miami plus three left go you went with
the Jets there yep disagreed on Vikings
Packer Sims going with the Vikings left
go going with the Packers in a pick'em I
also went bills and you went chargers
yeah I'm a sicko you are you did pick
that into the afternoon game I get it
right though it should be worth all you
have built what do you bet on it
$10 I guess you have 20 if you get there
right now let me mark that down for the
record here Wow guts to do that thanks
all of a sudden Sims is the house here
giving out money left and right Arizona
at the rim
Sims going with the Rams - 13 left go
taking the Cardinals they're humping a
tall dog and then uh last disagreement
here
Patriots Jaguars Sims going with the
Patriots left go going with the Jaguars
plus one and a half Oh let me go over my
quick love Cole ox before guarantee you
got a mix you know can I go take a pee
and could we cut for a second yeah yeah
okay left coast locks oh you let me do
it right now they're gonna pee are you
cool so what do you thing about this I'm
thinking I think I'm definitely a new
Pittsburgh just cuz I really like
Pittsburgh that might be when I go on a
limb by myself there okay
San Francisco Denver over Oakland so San
Francisco over Detroit Denver over
Oakland Pittsburgh over Kansas City and
I'm thinking Houston over Tennessee I
like all those is there anyone though
that I'm not saying that it's a little
bit more of a lock like I like
Washington Indy but Andrew Luck scares
me like I don't get as much scared from
Mariota
I don't patrick mahomes is a little
scary I know but I see your logic there
I mean I think if you got a pick locks I
think you're on the right track because
the only other ones I'm not gonna do
Green Bay I'm not gonna do Buffalo I'm
not gonna make Cleveland a lock I'm not
gonna do anything the only other one
would be Giants the only one would be
Giants over Kansas City or Pitt what do
you think Giants over Kansas what's more
of a lock pit by four I would trust pit
more I agree they're a better football
team I don't that did they they're not
gonna cover Pittsburgh all right and I'm
not gonna trust a rookie even though
he's that special to have to keep pace
and that first road game right okay dump
all right go take a pee all right Sims
is back from taking a pee pee and it's
time for a little GT know GTL guarantee
to lose Simms you took a beating on
social media last week because just like
left coast locks when people see the
word guarantee they think that it's
going to happen right I don't realize
that it's hard you went to two and one
you got the bills right you got the
Niners right you got a tie with the
Browns you got the Chiefs and Buccaneers
wrong it is now time for this week's
everybody had the Buccaneers moanin huh
everybody yeah guaranteed to lose Sims
where we start okay hey we're
starting in Pittsburgh okay you know
who's gonna lose sorry rookie
quarterback Patrick mahomes I love you
lots but you are gonna lose in your
first real road test against the
Pittsburgh Steelers at Big Ben
Roethlisberger picking the Chiefs for
the second straight week we'll see if it
burns up again hey nobody circles the
wagons like the Buffalo Bills whoa
there's no wagons a circle here you guys
were horrible last week all the wagons
left eeeh Dirty Diana sim says you're
gonna lose sorry that's my mama LA
Chargers x1 up guaranteed to lose we're
going to the bayou oh we're going to the
Bayou because I said if you want a
football game I might take you off but
you still haven't won yet ties so
Cleveland
I don't believe lend you will lose to
the New Orleans Saints see you next week
they can make cars they can't make
victories where we going next oh hey
we're going out to the west coast San
Francisco coal miners there they're
looking for gold and they found whoa
it's the Detroit lies and they stink
this is better than gold
nothing gets us on a winning streak than
this sorry
Detroit looked like the worst team in
football last week them were the bills I
don't know but they're gonna lose - Kyle
shinny on the San Francisco 49ers Oh
last one guarantee to lose it's a little
birdie that's getting a little squirty a
little hurt oh he's gonna be hurt he
because a Rams gonna run his ass over
sorry Arizona
you're gonna lose you're not even in the
same stratosphere I have the Los Angeles
Rams I am the Oracle therefore you shall
listen to me after a two two and one
week we'll see how Sims as on week two
of guaranteed to Lou Bava no guarantee
it if you were having someone the office
come up to you and said I have a
survivor pool what's the best team to
pick who would you tell them I told
Kenneth downstairs to pick Denver I
would tell him to take Arizona no you
take the Rams oh you picked the rand
yeah I would pick the Rams
to beat Arizona because he goes he goes
I need not a good team I need like a
medium team I was like was he saving all
the good teams
that'll happen yeah that would be my
pick what do you think about Denver
though is that the right move to tell
him I thought that's a little risky a
little risky all right that was that was
our betting show I
wanna give a special shout out to old
takes exposed it is the Twitter account
that calls out people when they get
things wrong randomly Sunday morning I
said screw that guy I'm gonna tweet at
him and ends up he's kind of a cool guy
and now he is making four picks every
Sunday against me I went three and one
last week he went one in three ah so
Sims a left go fandom make sure you give
old takes exposed to taste zone think
you've got exposed by Lepke locks how
you like them apples
alright we will be on social media all
day Sunday during the game so if you
follow Sims Aleph go at Adam left Co
we're gonna be on there with gifts with
memes kind of given our takes maybe a
selfie from Sims
yeah if Sims time is likely if Sims text
us some of his takes we might throw them
on their time fine but definitely follow
us on so I can together again we're
doing and then if you're not subscribed
to the podcast but you're listening to
us subscribe get your friends to
subscribe and again check out the
YouTube show Sims aleph go we think it's
pretty good and check out the big brain
on Sean McVeigh for Sims peace out
homies federic would say good evening
and the lef KO he man says holla holla
holla holla holla I still get a crack
that Sims laughs when Hendricks says
good evening talk to you guys later
85 episode good luck on your bets